but then we started to discover that it
had this other twist to it which was
that there was a lot of government
involvement and there the most alarming
three letters to see when you're going
through
documents that have been released to
your FBI or maybe CIA and so when you
start to see that in DHS and CDC
it's alarming and there was an
aggressive effort by the US government
to directly pressure the social media
platforms to censor disfavored voices
that's the simplest way to say it that's
what it was
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast I have the distinct pleasure of
sitting early this afternoon with
Michael schellenberger this is his
second visit to the Dark Horse podcast
uh for those of you who did not see our
first discussion I highly recommend it
it was done while I was on the road in
fact in the Very Room that Michael is
sitting in now the tech is a little iffy
but we managed to Cobble it together and
the quality of the discussion I thought
was excellent so anyway check that out
if you haven't seen it already for those
who haven't seen it and are going to
start with this second podcast let me
say
um is it fair Michael to say that we are
friends
good all right I feel I feel that we are
friends and I feel that at the same time
we were Arch enemies even if maybe you
weren't entirely aware of that were you
not aware of that
I was not aware of it but but I was
yours and and I didn't know but it was
never I never I never felt like you were
my enemy
you never detected that so what I mean
is that there's an issue the one on
which I first became aware of you
um on which I believe we still
substantially differ although I have
moved slightly in your direction partly
as a result of things that I've learned
from you
um I believe there is still a
fundamental sticking point and hopefully
I would love to reach agreement on on it
with you at some point um the issue is
fission power and whether it is a viable
uh solution to some or all of our energy
concerns my position is that the
actual Hazard of fission power is
dramatically under counted
um and anyway that is not going to be
the subject of this podcast but it is
where I first became aware of you you
having become a champion of fission
power as a potential solution your
argument being that it is substantially
greener than those of us who are spooked
by the hazards understand and I
certainly do get the argument but anyway
that is an argument we will postpone for
another day I look forward to having you
did it we had the argument
we we had part of it but I I have I am
in motion since that argument I'm hoping
that you are too and the the great thing
would be if we converged
and if not I will try to censor you
oh boy I did not see that coming now
we're back to Arch Enemy territory
um actually though more Amplified so
that I can debunk it publicly
right well before you get to debunking
now I'm not well versed in the tech in
in the terminology but I think you have
to pre-bunk and rebunk before debunking
I think that's how it's now done in
professional bunk circles we are
definitely pre-bunking is that is the
cool
sub field of disinformation studies that
is where it's at that and that in AI are
The Cutting Edge of censorship of the
censorship industrial complex so
well let's well that is good I mean that
is going to be the subject but I do want
to tell people that this is in some ways
as I count it maybe you'll count it
differently but your third public
Incarnation when I think back on all the
crap I learned in high school
it's a wonder I can't think at all
and though my lack of Education didn't
hurt me none
I can read the writing on the wall
our sponsor for this episode is
Hillsdale College if you were a few
decades out of school thinking back and
wondering what you learned you're not
alone
maybe you wish you had taken more time
to study topics that would be more
meaningful to you something lasting and
profound
so you are in this with a great many
others who don't understand what it is
they studied and why but it's not too
late since 1844 Hillsdale College has
been providing an education that focuses
on freedom and character because they
believe in a virtuous citizen no no no
they believe that a virtuous citizen is
the best defense for Liberty and they're
right about that and now they've taken
some of their core classes and made them
available online for free for anyone who
wants to learn time and Technology have
changed a lot of things but they have
not changed basic fundamental truths
about the world and our place in it
Hillsdale College
has an online range of courses that are
quite vast there are several on the
Constitution and on Congress the
presidency the Supreme Court there are
great books courses as well as courses
focused on the works of C.S Lewis Mark
Twain Shakespeare Jane Austen there are
history classes from ancient
Christianity to the rise and fall of the
Roman Republic to the second world war
and even classes on math and logic from
Euclid to Modern geometry
and one on the great principles of
chemistry over three million people have
taken a Hillsdale College online course
you could be next there are 39 free
courses to choose from they're all
self-paced so you can start whenever you
want in fact you can start right now
it's everything you need all in one
place with no long-term commitment learn
when and where you want enroll now in
hillsdale's not for credit online course
programs it's free it's fun and it will
change the way you understand our
country the world and your place in it
go right now to Hillsdale edu Darkhorse
to enroll there's no cost and it's easy
to get started that's
hillsdale.edu Darkhorse to register once
again
hillsdale-h-i-l-l-s-d-a-l-e.edu
Darkhorse our second sponsor for this
episode is Paleo Valley paleo Valley
makes a huge range of products
everything we've tried from them has
been terrific but we're going to talk
about just one of their product lines
today beef sticks paleo valleys beef
sticks are 100 grass fed and finished
now I don't know how you feed grass to a
beef stick but they've found a way they
are entirely organic and naturally
fermented the meat in these delicious
beef snacks comes from small
American-owned Farms that practice
rotational grazing paleo Valley makes
honest delicious products while many
beef products claim to have been
grass-fed often cows were only fed grass
for a portion of their lives and meat
can be marketed as American-made if it
was merely packaged in the U.S paleo
Valley doesn't play these games their
beef is from cows born and raised on
American soil entirely on grass and
these beef sticks are fantastic 100
grass-fed beef like in the Paleo Valley
beef sticks contains more calcium
magnesium potassium zinc phosphorus
beta-carotene and iron than grain-fed
beef it also has higher levels of
several B vitamins as well as a d e and
K which are understood to enhance
mineral and protein absorption
if you're thinking that paleo Valley's
beef sticks are Slim Jims you're wrong
for one thing unlike Slim Jim's paleo
Valley beef sticks contain no
mechanically separated chicken parts you
for another paleo Valley's beef sticks
are actually good for you ingredients
hiding in most beef sticks and jerky
include MSG hormones hydrogenated oils
and brominated vegetable oil which if
you're wondering what that is was first
patented as a flame retardant and now
it's in much of your food not if you buy
paleo valley though furthermore
virtually every meat snack on the market
is made with a processing agent called
encapsulated citric acid ECA which is
included to extend the shelf life of
those products but the health effects of
ECA on humans is unclear instead paleo
Valley beef sticks use natural
fermentation which gives the beef sticks
a long shelf life without the use of
harmful acids and chemicals and with the
added benefit of contributing to a
healthy gut paleo Valley beef sticks are
also keto friendly a great protein-rich
snack to grab when you're on the go like
running out the door for a meeting or
going on a bike ride and they're utterly
delicious paleo Valley doesn't cut
Corners they Source only the highest
quality ingredients and are passionate
about not only human health but
environmental restoration and Animal
Welfare as well they are a family owned
company try paleo Valley's beef sticks
today you will be so glad that you did
head over to
paleoveralley.com Darkhorse for 15 off
your first order
so I remember you as a champion of
fission power who leveled a
significant challenge to those of us who
were concerned about it then I became
aware of you again as you became a total
buzz kill on the topic of homelessness
and thoroughly destroyed any sense that
anyone might have rationally held that
the problem of homelessness is the
result of not enough housing you did
this by doing some very compassionate
interviews on the Streets of San
Francisco
I will at this point point out that
you've written a book called San
Francisco which I think every one of us
who mentions it trips over because it's
so close to the name of the town but
nonetheless you did some great work
revealing that you ran for governor the
uh power structure thoroughly trounced
you and made sure that you could not
wield power on behalf of the citizens of
California so congratulations to Goliath
on that one and then your third
Incarnation you have become a lead
reporter on the so-called Twitter files
and you have coined the term what was it
information industrial conflict
industrial complex it's uh I never take
too much credit for because it was so
obvious that that's what it was but yes
now those are the best ones that are
hiding in plain sight so you should take
credit
um uh so anyway what I want to do today
is talk to you about the questions
surrounding the information uh
industrial complex was in it yep no I've
got it wrong sensitive industrial
complex
censorship industrial industrial complex
okay so this is something that I have as
you know suffered from rather directly
um
as have you as has anyone who gets uh
gets it into their mind that truth
seeking might be a path forward for
Humanity you will run into this thing
and you will view it very differently
than anybody who is outside of that
realm could possibly right it looks very
different as it gets you than it does as
you try to navigate the world of
information yes
so do you want to orient us to the
Twitter files how you became involved
what you have discovered and then we can
get into some some deeper topics that I
think are yeah well that's a great way
to start Brett I mean I think that what
you've said it's a it's a call to
humility because
I do not think I would have cared about
this issue as deeply as I do had I not
been censored I did a spaces call as you
know yesterday on Twitter with Robert F
Kennedy Jr hosted by Elon Musk and David
Sachs
and um Robert Kennedy and I violently
disagree over nuclear speaking of
nuclear I don't agree that vaccines are
responsible for the increase of autism
um but I do share his concerns about
what's going on in Ukraine and I do
share his concerns about covid and and
and the ways in which That vaccine was
oversold
but the point is that he's been censored
too and that upsets us because we have
egos and would like to express ourselves
um but I think I think um I can't speak
for him but I think I would not be so
sensitive to had not talk affected me
personally so
um I put that out there to say we're all
sort of brutes on this issue we're all
sort of
um you know uh mugged by reality when
you're censored it's very humbling
especially if you're a proud person and
you think you are worth that you have
opinions that should be taken seriously
and you think you evaluate the evidence
so that happened to me in 2020 it
actually went asleep for me and I just
went back to my work because I felt like
I couldn't do anything about it
and then the Twitter files happened and
as your listeners no doubt know that
work started with concerns around seeing
the ways in which Twitter was engaged in
extremely biased censorship particularly
against covet Skeptics or Skeptics of
the vaccine as you might say
including very very famous ones very
prestigious ones at top universities
but then we started to discover that it
had this other twist to it which was
that there was a lot of government
involvement and there the most alarming
three letters to see when you're going
through
documents that have been released to
your FBI or maybe CIA and so when you
start to see that in DHS and CDC
it's alarming and there was an
aggressive effort by the US government
to directly pressure the social media
platforms to censor disfavored voices
that's the simplest way to say it that's
what it was
that's not legal that's not
constitutional you are not allowed as a
government the First Amendment says the
government shall not infringe on free on
freedom of expression and that means you
can't have somebody do it for you you
can't pay somebody else to do it you
can't subcontract it you can't be
involved with non-governmental
organizations doing it you can't be
encouraging it now you can correct what
you see on social media and you can ask
for fair response but you can't go and
ask for censorship that's a violation of
First Amendment and the courts are very
clear a clear violence and I would say
as somebody who has been censored
one of the problems with this landscape
is that it was clear that there was a
centrally controlled effort to silence
certain perspectives and to portray them
as scientifically invalid yes and it was
always unclear
you know you have this Baroque network
of organizations some of which are not
nominally governmental but they are
intermingled in such a way that the
First Amendment questions were obvious
from the get-go but the ability to make
a clear argument is almost dependent on
something like Discovery in other words
the normal way for the evidence that you
Unearthed in the Twitter files to emerge
would be for someone to sue something
like Twitter
and force the Revelation that they had
been instructed by governmental agencies
to censor or invited by governmental
agencies to censor
and the strange twist here is that Elon
Musk having purchased Twitter you know
as he famously said he bought a crime
scene right right and in buying a crime
scene he was able to make the evidence
uh public as a public service through
you and Matt taibi and others
um so anyway there was a strange turn of
events but I I do want to point out
absent that fact absent Elon Musk having
decided to reveal what he purchased in
his Twitter acquisition there is a
catch-22 that makes it very difficult
for the censored to fight back in the
way that the founders would have had us
do it which is that you have to be able
to make the case to a court that your
allegation that you are being that your
first amendment rights are being
violated by a private corporation like
Twitter uh basically withstands a smell
test right if if you don't have the
evidence that the government was in
involved in censoring you then it isn't
the First Amendment violation in all
probability
and a court might not be favorable
to your action and you'd be thrown out
of court so it required somebody
sympathetic with the First Amendment to
even discover that the evidence was
there that this involved government now
I do because this podcast may be
scrutinized later I do want to point out
there are legal reasons to believe that
actually it the government does not have
to participate directly in a censorship
action in order for the First Amendment
rights of a citizen to be violated but
we'll leave that for another day in this
case the government was involved it's a
clear violation yeah is that fair yeah
absolutely and um it's in the courts
um uh by covid critics
including Jay bhattacharya Aaron cariati
all the people that are familiar to your
your listeners
and I think they're going to win
um and
and I mean I hope they win um it's been
hard exactly for the reasons you say the
courts have not been where they need to
be in part because
I think there's also been some lack of
clarity which I feel like I've tried to
gain around what should be done and that
is that it's very hard to make the
social media platforms
Kerry's speech that that they don't want
to carry because that's also a violation
of the First Amendment because the first
amendment does not allow prescribed
speech of course that's the great
controversy that Jordan Peterson got
into in Canada was not uh he was
protesting originally when he became
famous the requirement that he be
required to use adopted pronouns rather
than natal birth pronouns for people and
in the United States the Supreme Court
has been very very clear on that issue
there's no doubt about you can't make
people say things so making social media
companies carries speech that they don't
want to carry is probably not going to
work
um and we don't want to have a we can't
have a government regulator of speech so
that what does that leave you with that
really leaves you with transparency that
you have some requirement that the
social media platforms must explain why
they are censoring me and I would go
further and say they must give me a
chance to the right to respond
and have a chance so that if I feel
unjustly or you feel unjustly
um frankly
disparaged discredited uh harmed by
being defamed by being de-platformed
there's actual there's psychological and
financial consequences to those
behaviors and so we should have a we
have a right to a remedy
and so I do think that that is up to the
Congress that it needs to do it
um we've also seen Elon Musk do more of
that at Twitter than they had done
previously and I of course
um and have stated so publicly encourage
him to do that and to do as much of it
as as possible but I do think it's
ultimately
the citizens of the world need to demand
that our governments require that level
of transparency which is why we are
um was delighted to do the podcast and
also to mention that we will be hosting
a free speech Alliance meeting in London
on June 23rd follow the night before
with a free speech event at West Central
Hall Westminster with Russell Brand Matt
taibi and me
and we're going to lay out the evidence
that governments have in fact been
censoring their citizens directly and
indirectly that this is absolutely
inconsistent with freedom with the
Enlightenment with the belief that free
speech is a fundamental human right as
well as an enabling
uh Foundation of democracy and free
markets and human progress and that
there has been no human progress without
free speech and that every liberatory
human human liberatory movement in
history and movement I would add of
Environmental Protection has required
more speech not less
and so we think that once the citizens
of the world see this
that they will
um a vast majority uh will want to have
free speech and that's basically what
we're proposing is that the world adopts
America's high levels of First Amendment
free speech and that governments simply
mandate
the transparency by social media
companies when they deprive citizens of
it
so I of course am very much in favor of
this I would point out that the
reasoning behind the importance of free
speech is
somewhat counter-intuitive which is why
many people who nominally would have
said they believed in it were also in
favor of censorship
but I would also point out that
there is a reason that we don't all
simply agree on this that the power
gained through the suppression of speech
is
um
cannot really be overstated right to the
degree that you can control speech you
can control everything and so therefore
this really is the central battle
um now the
there is of course going to be an arms
race to the extent that you were able to
discover the ways in which the
government or our governments really uh
imposed their will on
uh on this medium
um
was because they did not realize that
what they were doing was going to be
reviewed right as soon as they
understand that it will be reviewed then
they will go through something akin to
you know the economic equivalent would
be holding companies or something used
to obscure the ownership of some
property right the mandates that are
discovered through a process like the
Twitter files will be hidden you know
they will be veiled and so anyway uh no
one should imagine that just because we
may be on the verge of waking up and
reaffirming our commitment to free
expression of ideas that the battle will
be over this is a forever battle and I
believe the founders understood that
um so that's that's where we find
ourselves ourselves
um do you want to put some color on
what it is beyond the jaw-dropping fact
of the U.S federal government and its
various agencies pressuring
social media companies to censor
citizens who were frankly
not only doing something that was
protected right vile speech is protected
but this was the Federal Government
actually interfering with the right of
citizens
to even discuss questions of their own
health and the wisdom of certain
policies that the government was
advancing right so this is actually
citizens engaged in responsible behavior
who were being censored and stigmatized
and defamed at the behest of the federal
government that's really a shocking
shocking fact so I was hoping that you
would tell us a little bit about the
details of how that how that functions
yeah what did you see in the Twitter
files yeah and just to go back to some
of you said where I think you were like
they didn't know they were going to get
away with it what I would the way I
would say it is the people doing it
thought they uh or they didn't know that
they would be discovered I think you
said yeah um I think that they thought
they would get away with it I think they
thought that they were doing so if you
look at what they were doing they would
do things like write articles have
reports they're all publicly available
they would even make videos
and one of my colleagues I think one of
the most important of the censorship
leaders the uh a very influential policy
advocate for censorship in the
censorship industry named Renee diresta
she's a former CIA fellow
um when a colleague of mine watched her
video and he said she's so boring how do
people listen to her she's so boring and
I was like and I remember I remember
there was a moment where I thought she
was boring too but I also knew there was
something going on and then by the time
this colleague said that I was like well
actually she's like one of the most
interesting people by far
um you have to understand what she's
saying she's actually describing how the
first amendment is a problem and how
they need to create these ways to get
around it she called her talk to the
Department of Homeland Security's cyber
security and infrastructure Security
Agency
uh almost a name designed to make you
forget what it is or how to say it
um she said this is about the power of
Partnerships and we're going to partner
with the government so we can engage in
censorship secretly behind closed doors
without anybody noticing it
um but in front of all of you that I'm
describing in this clear language so she
did it you know like a 10 or 15 minute
talk
I then well we responded and we did a
video where we kind of had me describing
what she was actually saying and when
you get down to it that is what she's
saying she's saying we need to help
censor because the government
can't do it it was that speech she gave
that then leaves the the Biden
Administration to publicly announce a
so-called disinformation governance
board in the spring of last year
which was immediately shouted down
um and uh
um
I also we also discovered that Barack
Obama a week before that governance
board had been announced had made the
case for The Identical kind of
censorship government agency a kind of
agency to control speech and then they
sort of
and then when you challenge them on it
they kind of run away from it and they
go well but why are you saying the
government has a right to speak to of
course the government should be able to
speak and that's all it's doing and so
they end up in a kind of retreating to a
kind of you know sophomore philosophical
conversation about how it's all just the
same it's all just speech and it's all
just you know and that also there is
content moderation so I think the other
thing you have to understand is that
there's content moderation going on Elon
censored us while you know sensors of
swastika they censor child pornography
there's all sorts of censorship that
goes on and they sort of then kind of
get they try to kind of then suggest
that that it's all just in that level
rather than say
people describing very real side effects
from vaccines or people suggesting that
it doesn't make sense to keep kids home
from school or does it make sense to
mask children or
um that uh you know natural disasters
aren't actually getting worse you know
um or you know various things that they
sort of that they've then sort of got
they've sort of used the conventional
wisdom to then lump
uh minority views into the same category
as the swastikas and the child porn
so
all right a couple of things that I want
to come back to here one at the point
that and I was one of the people uh I
don't really like the characteristic or
the uh the characterization of shouting
down the information governance board or
whatever the hell that was but I was one
of the people critiquing it Heather and
I uh talked about it extensively and
um right
oh we we have been demonetized we were
demonetized over talking about vaccine
safety and Effectiveness and repurposed
drugs and early treatment for covid and
have never been remonetized
um so they you know this has had a very
serious material impact
on my family's well-being literally half
of our Emily income obliterated by
YouTube
uh and frankly the things that they
claim for misinformation uh weren't but
there's no appeals process as you point
out but I wanted to go back to at the
point that the public outcry arose over
the information governance board or
whatever their euphemism for Ministry of
Truth was
they engaged in you know you say it's
sophomoric I say it's sophistry
right that one of the weapons that are
being used to disguise many things which
are indefensible are arguments that are
designed to befuddle right these are
wrong arguments that are hard to
untangle they can bury you in them
faster than you can untangle them and so
the argument was that the claim that
this information governance board was a
threat to freedom of speech was itself
Miss dis and malinformation or something
right
view over this podcast will know Miss
dis and Mal information was actually an
invention of the Department of Homeland
Security that misinformation amounts to
errors disinformation amounts to lies
and Mal information amazingly enough
amounts to things that are based in
truth but cause you to distrust your
government in other words the kinds of
things that we have an absolute
obligation to discuss right the fact
that our government may be untrustworthy
if that's true we should be discussing
it it can't be and not only uh sorry
don't mean to rant at you Michael
but not only did the Department of
Homeland Security Define Miss dis and
malinformation as things to be worried
about and controlled but they literally
defined them as a form of terrorism yeah
right misinformation errors a form of
terrorism disinformation lies a form of
terrorism does that make humor terrorist
and then Mal information true things
that cause you to distrust your
government that's terrorism I thought it
was our patriotic obligation to talk
about these things so here you have the
federal government literally
using a magic term terrorism to
eliminate the rights of people engaged
in speaking true things about the
government that might cause people to be
alarmed right that's an amazing fact of
history yet very few people are even
aware that it happened
right it's like a it's one of these
things like you can view it on the web
it's not that it was undocumented but
yet if you mention it to people it
sounds like a wild-eyed conspiracy
theory yes right that's that's that's
one it's its own defense because it's
unbelievable well in conspiracy theories
we did a piece today about conspiracy
theories and it's important to keep in
mind how many true things have been
labeled conspiracy theories let's just
take three we're just going to take the
top three that everybody agrees Hunter
Biden's laptop was Hunter Biden's laptop
um it was not a conspiracy theory
um and in fact
um the alternative explanation was a
conspiracy theory which is that somehow
the Russians did it and there was no it
was a there were two waterlogged um
laptops that the Biden in his drunken
stupor dropped into his bathtub and gave
to a computer store to repair that's
what it was they had the subpoena from
the FBI the receipt from the FBI
confiscating the laptop published in the
New York Post so the conspiracy theory
was that it was anything other than what
it absolutely appeared to be and that
New York Post had the proof of so that's
number one number two covid lab leak
Theory
um it was dismissed the near the
Washington post's original headline was
Tom Cotton repeats debunked conspiracy
theory they then changed the headline
stealthily not acknowledged in the in
the corrections
um and
um in fact not only had there been many
many lab leaks in the past it had been
the subject of front page newspaper
coverage by USA Today which noted that
when they occurred the people that had
them occur on their watch tried to cover
them up and moreover there had been
debates involving Anthony fauci in lab
leak concerns we're President Obama
sides against fauci and bansgan a
function resources these are all things
that your your listeners know very well
but the third would be that the Pentagon
is covering up evidence of UFOs
that may still sound like a conspiracy
to some people who have not been paying
attention to the news but anybody else
knows that since 2017 the Pentagon has
acknowledged that it is studying UFOs it
is now its own program called arrow and
we had another Pentagon whistleblower
come forward to yesterday so what we're
seeing is
there's that's just three examples of
major things that were dismissed as
conspiracy theories all that have been
proven uh to be real things in the last
uh you know a few years and so
conspiracy theory is something that I
think we should understand to be like
the word disinformation it's a word
assigned by people in power to hijack
our brains and get us to stop thinking
and get us to stop thinking critically
yes and in fact if you dig on that term
you will find that and I'm not going to
claim that the debate is perfectly
settleable in either direction but you
will find that the CIA is actually
interested in advancing that concept to
dispel alternative explanations for the
John F Kennedy assassination yeah
I also check when I checked that I read
that that was a conspiracy theory
that's exactly why I say it's unresolved
I believe I've seen the documents the
documents are real the question is what
exactly is the CIA trying to do in this
case and it could be ambiguous but
here's the larger point
you mentioned three conspiracy theories
that we all now acknowledge
one of the three that you mention I
believe believe could be or is likely to
be uh a double reversal
yes you phrase it very carefully you
have
um government programs to study what are
now euphemistically called uaps
whereas UFO is a perfectly viable
description it didn't claim that they
were aliens it just said we couldn't
identify them right
um but here's the thing
the
information that now suggests that we
are to take uaps or UFOs seriously
itself has the appearance of a
government psyop that the government
would like us now to be focused on this
and all of the things that constitute
evidence in this quest in this realm are
questionable in their own right so I
want to connect that back to something
else you mentioned Renee diresta in the
interest of full disclosure I know Renee
diresta not well but I've broken bread
with her
um it's not surprising to me at all that
she has a CIA background but am I
mistaken in recalling a in fact very
recent podcast in which you and Renee
and Barry Weiss and Sam Harris gathered
so
first of all tell us tell us about that
this is not a caught red-handed thing
I'm not saying gotcha I'm just saying
interesting that you would be talking
about Renee diresta as a
um as the most fascinating boring person
in history by virtue oh no I don't think
she's boring at all
right right that's right yeah yeah no no
I think it's superficially boring no no
I think she's a I think she's dangerous
and needs to be disempowered and has
been disempowered by our research and
our writing
um I think she's the I mean I'm not
saying there's not somebody else behind
her but I actually whether or not there
is and I think it might be Michael
mcfaul or at least she's someone she
that she works closely with and he's
ostensibly her boss at Stanford
um I think she's the one that's done the
most important intellectual work to make
the case for censorship and to do
censorship and to actually actively
censor people like you
um
so um I mean I've written a lot about it
people should read uh most importantly
just called why Renee diresta leads the
censorship industry that's the the big
piece that we did on her but also she's
in both of my congressional testimonies
um and also discussion on Joe Rogan but
um she's a fascinating person
um I uh on the podcast with Sam I did
not yet understand what how important
she was I knew she was important but I
didn't know
I didn't know that what she had done
with the election Integrity project and
the virality project which were the two
main censorship programs in 2020 and
nor did I understand
is it fair to say sorry I don't mean to
interrupt you but is it fair to say you
did not know it's not just that the
extent of her importance that you didn't
know but you didn't know in what way she
was important nor did I he was
overseeing the censorship program nor
had she talked about it um or had made
much hay of it um
um certainly not on the podcast she's
very very disciplined and careful with
how she talks in every situation
um having now watched many hours of
Renee diresta in various contacts and
she's always
she's um you know she's interesting she
always is sort of the number two person
but yeah she's always obviously smarter
than the number one guy
um you know she has this whole I think
completely contrived and ridiculous
um background story that she was just a
Nancy that she was just a a pro-vaccine
mom
[Music]
um that's all and she just started uh
being concerned about disinfo on
Facebook I don't believe any of it
um she then suddenly found herself
advising Obama on fighting Isis
which is just this bizarre I mean when
you understand how hierarchical Military
Intelligence cultures are to kind of
imagine some hobbyist pro-vaccine mom
from the Bay Area suddenly advising
Obama on fighting Isis is just absurd
um yep so um she's a fascinating person
um you know I I don't want to spend I
try not to overemphasize it because for
two reasons one I I don't want to
personalize it because it isn't a
personal issue actually
um I think I share some common views of
covid and homelessness for example
um you know I think she's higher in a
personality description she'd be higher
on orderliness
and industriousness I bet she's pretty
high on conscientiousness
um I think that's the type of person
that has not cared for the open drug
scenes and open drug dealing nor do I
think she's uh nor do I think she was a
climate alarmist I think actually she
was probably really opposed to the
stay-at-home orders for kids
so I want to remain human about this
um I I suspect like I've always said I'm
sure like under private life she might
be a perfectly good person but the work
she did censoring ordinary Americans is
absolutely unethical violates the
Constitution she needs to be held to
account for it she is being sued right
now
um she did better so wait wait and she
abused power and there's and she's been
secretive and there's a lot more going
on than she's been honest about
so
um I don't want to personalize this but
I do think the example of Renee duresta
is so significant
that we need to spend a little time here
and it doesn't have to be personal at
all in fact I would say look Renee if
you're watching
come clean
right what you did was unpatriotic the
route back is to tell us about it how
did it happen how did you find yourself
doing this work that any rational person
would understand is a violation of our
most important constitutional right and
as somebody who was a victim of that I
will welcome you with open arms if
you'll come clean about the whole thing
so that we as Citizens can understand
what it is and we can fix our structure
so this isn't personal
but I do want to point out am I correct
Renee diresta has been a guest on Joe
Rogan's program yes
yes guest on Joe Rogan's program I ran
into her at a conference of let's just
say
intellectually minded people who had
gathered to talk about the important
issues of the day a conference that was
put together just for people to gather
and discuss important things okay
um
you find yourself on a podcast with
Renee daresta and Sam Harris Sam Harris
who has played his own role now Sam
Harris is not a government entity he is
not obligated to be truthful or decent
or analytically consistent or anything
so I'm not suggesting that Sam has
violated any uh principle other than
common decency in what he did but the
fact that you who are now one of the
most important nodes in the dissident
Network fighting this cryptic
suppression of speech found yourself
podcasting effectively on a team with
Sam Harris Renee diresta and Barry Weiss
is fascinating and my point is not
really about Renee diresta it's about
whatever it is that Renee diresta is
doing the phony story that you point to
couldn't possibly be right where as a
you know pro-vaccine Mom she finds
herself uh advising the Pentagon
well that same
uh
unbelievableness accompanies her
movement through the sphere of people
trying to make sense of the world and
how much does it have to do with for
example Sam Harris's profound confusion
of late right I will point out to you
that Renee deresta is Central to the
story of both
the suppression of actual information
and Analysis on covid but also the Biden
laptop story during the election right
so and and Sam had uh Renee on as a
guest uh on the now thoroughly debunked
Russian collusion story so
also so I guess my point is it is not
surprising I said I'm happy to say
something about Sam
well I would love for you to um as you
probably know my relationship with Sam
has become very complicated and I hold
Sam responsible for that but Sam is also
somebody I would welcome back with open
arms if he would come clean about what
happened
I mean my view of cm is that first of
all I really loved his book
um the end of faith and I I love I think
the meditation stuff is important
um I think uh you know in terms of
expanding the range of human potential
and human creativity
um I think pushing back on Islam is is
important although I also think it can
be a religion of peace and love I really
believe that
um but you know Sam has a very wrong
core worldview
um that is sort of astonishing in its
Simplicity and childlike kind of nature
which is
what I think he calls philosophical
realism but it basically doesn't deal
with any of the most important ideas of
philosophical thought of the last 300
years starting with Hume and the notion
that we're actually driven by emotions
and instincts and that we're ironically
for someone who says he's an atheist and
says that we're driven by emotions and
passions he has I think a great
overestimation of his ability to avoid
being trapped in various emotionally and
proud and pride bound arguments that
have to do with his own overestimation
of his abilities
and I think also as platonic and
fundamentally believes that sort of the
world is apprehended by science and that
the world somehow stays the same but of
course it doesn't and so when you look
at something like vaccine efficacy my
colleague Alex gutentag is really
helping me understand better
but particularly this person Norman
Fenton has done this extraordinarily I
think helpful explanation of how they
manipulated
um the claims around vaccine efficacy
uh claiming uh 95 percent uh relative
efficacy for vaccines that were less
than one percent absolute efficacy and
never explaining the difference to
people which is just dishonest immoral
unethical
um but that also that those rates of
efficacy change with different variants
over time and with population Dynamics
and so the idea that you would pre-bunk
something about a vaccine's efficacy in
the future to describe in the present to
describes in the future is grossly
unscientific it's absolutely
metaphysical it's basically a religious
view we know what the truth is going to
be next year on a fast changing rapidly
changing virus and pandemic it's it's
ridiculous it's absolutely absurd
um what's more we simply do not decide
what's good or bad based uh on science
um science uh tells us what is Hume is
correct uh you cannot derive what ought
to be from an is at least not in any
sort of direct way or without some
broader appeal to human morality human
morality is complex it's important it's
it exists in institutions there's all
sorts of
type 1 thinking involved in it which
actually have been protective of
cultures it's um so I think he's got a
view of the world that is I just think
just almost childlike in its Simplicity
and its wrongness it's debunked every
every philosophy student in college was
to get rid of that stuff when they study
Hume
you know and when they study basic
philosophy and basic cognitive science
and he seems to think he's got this
picture of the world that the experts
are are more right than wrong and more
right than the public but Philip tetlock
debunked even that showing that expert
predictions about the future are no
better than the average prediction of
others which are no better than
um than random because we're terrible
terrible terrible at predicting the
future because we're terrible at
predicting human behavior and we're
terrible at predicting Collective human
behavior in the future so I just found I
find Sam
he made an interesting polemical
intervention around Islam but since then
it's honestly been scientistic reductive
hubristic
um and I think that's why he ends up
finding himself taking advantage of
grifters and uh censor
you know um so that's my that's my view
and
um I don't I think it's terrible
philosophy I think it's terrible moral
philosophy it makes for absolutely
authoritarian instincts from somebody
who claims to be on the side of the
Enlightenment the enlightenment
questions on free speech and scientific
inquiry were resolved hundreds of years
ago which is that you allow wrong speech
because wrong speech anybody that's ever
been involved in science or journalism
or anything wrong speech is necessary
often
for uh for getting things right
you know you often sorry you often have
to be wrong before you're right and so
we we encourage wrongness we like
longness yep
it's UFO around here
oh goodness
um so look that's a great rant it
dovetails with a lot of the things that
I've concluded about Sam myself and I've
done more thinking about him than I
would like to have as a result of his
very aggressive posture that he has
taken towards yeah me and Heather over
the course of the pandemic you'll be
happy on that podcast I defended Jay
bhattacharya's honor
in real time by Googling what remember
Sam was claiming and showing that Sam
was grossly misrepresenting it
right there on the podcast so anyway
there you go
somehow Sam has become uh like the
universe's way of teaching us about
irony right and the importance of
humility
the importance of humility and also I
think he is a cautionary tale about
rationalism right rationalism is a
lovely idea that cannot be
operationalized for the human reasons
that you're talking about right we you
just simply don't have that you know uh
30 000 foot view of all of these issues
from which you can Purge uh your you
know emotional state and all of that and
it is Sam's belief that he can that he
can drive in his from a not or not from
an is
um that has him resulting in all of
these odd places including having Renee
diresta on his program multiple times to
spread misinformation in the guise of a
sense making podcast right so that's an
amazing fact but again I want to come
back to not the person of Renee diresta
but the lesson that the rest of us have
to take right
I don't know what to make of the fact I
mean
Joe Rogan is a good friend of mine
right
he's had
a person who is Downstream of the CIA
and who has apparently been Central in
the process that has been censoring me
and trying to censor him that's a very
complex reality to be in it's a very
it's a Hall of Mirrors of a level that
we do not anticipate I am now sitting
here talking to you somebody who I
thought initially might be a shill for
the the nuclear industry
right but having come together over
other issues so at some level I would
just say everybody needs to take the
lesson of this
it's possible that
people in our midst are not what they
appear to be and it is possible that
people who appear not to be what they
appear to be actually are what they
appear to be which is now what I take
you to be right I take you to be an
honest broker and the reason that I
think that you're an honest broker is
because I've now seen you across
multiple domains take a difficult stance
out of what I read to be principle so
okay
no I appreciate that thank you
yeah yeah no you're welcome but I guess
I guess the point is look
a lot of people have misjudged Renee
diresta in the other direction they have
taken her to be an honest broker and
that does not appear to be the
explanation for what she is her her
backstory appears to be a cover story
right
I mean so much is changing and the media
are allowing the the new Communications
Technologies are allowing us to have
much more um interesting richer complex
conversations that we simply were not
allowed to have in the era of one-way
broadcast
um and it's it's creating all sorts of
the the elites are freaking out about it
they don't get to dominate uh public
Consciousness in the way that they did
and they're trying to get they try to
get control of social media and they
basically were they don't they had
basically achieved it
until this gigantic swerve ball you know
Elon whenever I think about Elon you
kind of go boy throw away all the books
that were written because you know
lucretius by the way wrote this
beautiful uh these you know beautiful
writings the Greek philosopher and he
had because he was a atheist sort of
believed that there was that world was
sort of random and that there were these
swerve events and it was sort of a
really
like it's important to not be
deterministic and also really understand
the the power of the American experiment
because Elon
really came out of nowhere like you that
is not something you can look at the
laws of history or or the patterns I
mean we were truly headed towards a very
totalitarian Society whereby a very
small number of people I mean think
about it the mainstream lately they got
all the mainstream news media together
at Aspen to quote unquote pre-bunk
hunderbine's laptop they had all these
newspapers there but they only really
needed two social media platforms so
whereas you had this heterogeneity even
in the news media suddenly you get the
social media platforms and you basically
have one or two that allow for the
security State the medical State the the
you know corporate interests we now see
exert this extraordinary control over
these over these platforms and um so we
came very close to that but there was a
swerve and so I think there should be
humility humility for me is the thing
that keeps coming up
you know that we should all be more
humble and that's hard to do at an
environment where the social media is
such that it both magnifies ego
and it um I think it reinforces
dogmatism that's part of the reason I
think the left
has become so dogmatic though I don't
think it entirely explains it
um but I think it's a so for me I go
this moment is so amazing we should be
humbled by the fact that our our
knowledge is always temporary there's
very few Eternal truths the ones that we
have are very important too including I
think some amount of humility and
curiosity
um and I actually kind of go I know
you've been roughed up the last couple
of years I certainly was in 20 in 2020
in particular but I do also think
um things change you know I mean if you
just look at what's going on with the
lab League my own views of the vaccine
have changed after I saw the Norman
Fenton stuff
and I think it really helped me to see
that so I think that I know you've been
wanting to see this conversation abroad
and I do think you're starting to get
that you know on a lot of the issues
that you care the most about
yes
um I maybe this is a good moment to
actually just give a status report on
that
um I see there being
3.5 major legs of the coven question
one was lab leak
two was vaccine safety and Effectiveness
three was repurposed drugs and early
treatment and the 0.5 is the
relationship between our
covid response and the proliferation of
new coveted variants
and what I would say one thing that I
look I like I like your humility thing
but I think we need to break it into two
pieces
one
in the circles that I travel people talk
about what they call epistemic humility
yeah right
and it's not the same thing as personal
humility it may be related but the
recognition that you can be dead wrong
on stuff and that you need to navigate
with the knowledge that it may always be
that you are stepping out on Ice that
seems thicker than it is and it turns
out you were wrong and the ability to
gracefully retrace your steps and take
the correct path
is the key to navigating confusing
issues like these
I would caution you I've heard you say a
couple things
uh already in this podcast these are
places where I have the sense
um
there may be an Awakening
the deeper you dig right Norman Fenton
may be the very clear early indication
of something very wrong in this covet
space
but the full depth of what's wrong
um requires a certain amount of uh
digging and it requires you to basically
take all that you've learned from the
Twitter Files about everything that was
done to take the voices that needed to
be listened to and to sideline them
right and imagine that some very
different conversation would have
happened if that had not occurred
a conversation that is now lost to
history we will never have it right but
the point is what would the conclusion
of that conversation have been if we did
have it that's what you're looking for
right if we had navigated in the forward
Direction whereas we all agreed at the
door that the purpose of the discussion
was to figure out what the truth of
covet was the truth of where it came
from the truth of what that implies
about its likely evolutionary trajectory
the truth of whether or not there were
early treatments to be had irrespective
of whether or not they were profitable
to anyone the truth about the novel
technologies that were introduced there
uh safety they're likely Effectiveness
their utility or lack thereof in
controlling the spread of the disease
right all of these things would have had
a very different trajectory and I would
just argue that I believe as much as I
think a small handful of dissidents that
came together
were brought together by covid did break
the back of the narrative
we have not managed to Lodge the
replacement for it which is a correct
analytical understanding of the evidence
and what it implies about this disease
and our responses to it so uh there are
still layers to go right discovering
that there was suppression and that it
was not completely successful
is part of it inferring what discussion
would have happened had it been gone is
the other and wow is that it did rabbit
hole
let's ask
so anyway
yeah
um
so there are a couple topics I want to
make sure that we cover today
um I guess when I reached out about
having you back on Dark Horse the
primary one that I wanted to get to
was the issue that you recently reported
on of FBI whistleblowers and the
treatment of them
so could you summarize that story for
people yeah that's that's I'm glad you
asked so
this is
so we have so basically the the short
version of the basic facts of the matter
are that multiple FBI whistleblowers
have come forward what they have alleged
is that there is internal pressure
within FBI but also stems as as you
might imagine from external pressure
including from the White House in
Congress
to go after so-called domestic terrorism
there is no evidence of any increase
much less a significant increase in
domestic terrorism domestic terrorism is
extremely rare events if you think of
Ruby Ridge or Waco or Timothy McVeigh or
911 extremely rare events so anything
you could say about rare events is
necessarily
trans science if you would even call it
that it's not particularly there's no
you can't do any significant statistical
analysis of it
um and so the way you've seen is these
guys are reporting things like trying to
increase the entrap the entrapment of
mentally ill people or mentally impaired
or just maybe people that you might have
called
you know in the past we might have
called [__] you know people that do
not have high IQs you see
um similar entrainments like we saw
after 9 11.
um we see reports you know uh we now we
all you know relatedly we see um we we
now know there's testimony of
potentially hundreds of government
agents Undercover
or as assets for various domestic
intelligence and law enforcement
organizations at the January 6 protest
and capital riot
there's a whole separate January 6th
conversation to have because there is
more there than people say and certainly
people go far beyond what the facts show
as well
but nonetheless I think the picture has
been an effort by FBI and particularly
by democrats and particularly by the
Biden White House to drum up uh domestic
terrorism threat focused on the people
that you would exactly expect them to be
going after which are Trump voters
Republicans populists
um you know uh
conservatives mostly but they you know
there's some famous cases of they went
after some you know a group of black
left-wing socialists who were
uh you know uh pro-russia we've seen
them go after ant you know anti-ukraine
War leftists like the gray Zone at least
in terms of censorship not I'm not
suggesting um FBI although one of their
reporters was just detained by British
intelligence
so you see a kind of Crackdown going on
in FBI that mirrors the sort of
censorship Crackdown it's as though you
get the feeling when you re when you
research these two things side by side
and report on them that there is a
concerted effort to frame a significant
share of the American people as domestic
terrorists violent extremists or
potential domestic terrorists and
potential domestic extremists frankly I
find it sickening we've we've seen that
we've been debunked
wait wait I think I think frankly you're
okay go ahead a little bit right
for for people who are Maybe
a little younger and don't really
understand the game
what this is is the weaponization
of
clandestine elements of the executive
branch against political antagonists
right this is an attempt to create a
phony version of history that justifies
whatever the blue team wants to do
and an attack
on political adversaries that happens to
use magic terminology that literally
triggers Provisions that should never
have been installed in the American
legal structure that
unhook people's constitutional rights
without the awareness that it has even
happened
I don't know if that description sounds
uh no I don't think you overstated it at
all that's what's happening and it's
upsetting and disturbing and you know
I'll give you an example I'll give you
another thing we're working on right now
we started seeing a lot of people Biden
Obama the media think tanks start to
make a claim that anti-Semitism is
sharply increasing and there's some big
increase of anti-Semitism well you go
look at the data I mean I I take offense
at like three levels to this the first
level I take offense is the just the
grotesque abuse of the science and the
lack of anybody even mentioning it they
are not factoring in an increase of
reporting in these various measures of
anti-Semitism so they they can say
they've seen more reports well we
actually have very good research
including quantitative research showing
something called concept creep which is
that the Public's own view of what is
harmful is increasing business gets
talked about in the context of gen Z
being very sensorious and not wanting
people to say certain things because
they get injured by speech but we've
also seen a think tank in Britain has
mislabeled posts critical of George
Soros and the world economic Forum as
anti-semitism
this is um so first of all I find that
offensive as somebody that cares about
reality and Truth the second way it's
offensive is that if you are Jewish
and you are actually concerned about
safety and the historical
pattern then you do not want people
going out there and suggesting an
increase of anti-Semitism where there is
not one that's called messing with the
baby
it's called monkeying with the Baseline
I agree but
I this is one of these issues that
drives me a little bit crazy right
because it let's take climate change is
another one okay here's something I can
guarantee you
a lot of climate change research and the
discussion that flows from it is garbage
doesn't mean climate change isn't real
right
for me I use as a barometer The Retreat
of glaciers
right glaciers function as a kind of
Integrative measure of warming
I've been promised an ice-free Arctic
for decades now there's never been a
nice free Arctic so I know something's
overblown on the other hand I don't see
glaciers uh
failing to retreat I see them retreating
but Kilimanjaro still has them Etc so
anyway my point is on the in the case of
climate change we have both the reality
of climate change and the abuse of
climate change in order to justify
things that are basically somebody's
private interest okay both things are
happening simultaneously
I have the sense that this is also the
case with the claims about anti-Semitism
and the reason I say that and mind you
I'm I'm an anecdote to be sure
but I didn't ever used to encounter
anti-Semitism right it was not a factor
in my life I'm sure people had fleeting
thoughts upon meeting me oh he's Jewish
and then maybe they had some thought but
it didn't manifest in a difference in
treatment that I could detect right
that is no longer the case I now run
into overt anti-Semitism regularly right
that could be the change in my position
in the world and that I'm encountering
something that was there all along or it
could be that there's something in our
social space that is experimenting with
making anti-Semitism tolerable again
where for a long time after the end of
World War II it was understood to be a
no-go Zone across civilization right so
my what I I'm not arguing that your
presentation isn't right that there
isn't an abuse of claims of
anti-Semitism for purposes that have
nothing to do with actually protecting
anybody from anything right but I don't
want to synonymize that and say just
because there's [__] on this channel
that the channel isn't also about
something real because my personal
experience says yes something about
anti-Semitism has become permissible
again and we are seeing something that
at least personally looks like a major
uptick you yeah I I haven't seen the
evidence for it I mean we've looked at
it
um
I'm not saying it's not there I'm just
saying I haven't seen the evidence for
it I I have not seen anybody attempt to
account for uh changes in reporting
which the increases of the reporting and
this is important are are increases we
see across all religious categories so
we see increasing reports of hate speech
across all categories now you combine
that with the fact that Jews are the
most uh warmly popular viewed religious
group and have been for a very long time
I suspect it does go back to the
Holocaust in World War II but Jews are
have according to the Pew research and
they've been researching it for a very
long time
63 is the mean thermometer rating for
Jews Catholics is 6D Protestant 60
Buddhist 57 Evangelical Christians 56
Hindus 55 Mormons 51 atheists and
Muslims are tied at 49. so you know it's
just not the case I just think
it's it's you know
I think it's very dangerous actually to
go out and suggest an increase of hate I
think it's often I have the same
reaction should I do for the
disinformation
and the conspiracy theory and that I
think that when they start talking about
that there's an agenda at work they're
wanting to do censorship and they're
looking to demonize people and I think I
can't help but think it's it's actually
aimed out of a larger strategy to frame
the populists particularly populist
right but to some extent to which it
still exists populist left
as anti-semitic because it actually fits
a particular historical parallel and
again I'm not saying there's not
anti-Semitism I'm not saying a thing
about whether support for Palestine is
you know whatever that means I'm not
even suggesting that I'm just saying in
the sort of metrics that they we all
agree to use of what would count as
anti-Semitism I get very concerned when
people start suggesting they're seeing a
pattern there when we really don't have
any evidence for it
well I would suggest another
interpretation and then we can move on I
think we both made our positions clear I
don't detect a difference in the average
person's View at all right I think in
the U.S uh I experience essentially no
anti-Semitism on average
but what I am encountering that I never
encountered before is
overt stuff like uh
Holocaust denial like a theme on Twitter
uh where you know in fact I just ran
into it this week somebody cited
somebody who has wanted an intellectual
argument with me and has been sort of
gunning for it posted a link to another
account and I clicked through on that
account and they're pinned tweet was
something about
um
I believe
the Nazis were bad people because of a
bunch of movies that were made by
Jews who
wanted me to think that or something
like that right it was some sort of uh
Nazi uh
because Holocaust style of version at a
very the very least yeah
right now
you know Nazi
Holocaust denialism I know exists it
always exists
but it's rare enough
that I've almost never encountered it in
person
right I now encounter it with some
regularity right and right there on
Twitter and mind you when I saw this
account did I report it no my feeling is
I actually would rather that these
people
speak and we know that they're out there
and we can assess whether they're
becoming more common or not
um than to have some you know
I don't want to justify their fantasies
that they're being oppressed by anybody
right I would like them to get the [__]
over it but whatever but nonetheless my
point is
again my average interaction with other
Americans
I don't detect anti-Semitism but the
rate at which I encounter things that I
find surprising things that would not
have been discussed in the open 10 15
years ago that are now regularly
discussed in the open I do think that
represents the increase in something so
your model That You Don't See you know
that people feel warmly towards Jews
cool that's not inconsistent with what
I'm seeing no but what I am seeing is
over on The Fringe I'm seeing yeah but I
mean as a scientist I think you would
agree that we would want to see some
data and so there is they do have they
the people that are making this claim
are presenting data of increasing
reports without factoring for concept
creep or for the fact that it's that
it's increasing along all groups in fact
there's more people but but it doesn't
you in social science obviously you have
to account for those um reporting errors
and um and Reporting biases and and
instead of I mean you know you have to
back up and kind of go keep in mind it's
like Barack Obama is somebody that
actually you wanted you was somebody you
would actually count on to somebody that
would not make a claim like that without
actually having looked at it and I see
no evidence that he was like hey um did
we account for a reporting bias or what
is the real research on this
um it's been irresponsible it's been
used politically it's Ada L it's it's
splc
um they and who by the way we wrote a
whole piece yesterday just on how they
refused to give interviews we've gone to
over 50 of these organizations 10 of
them replied only one has agreed to an
interview so these are groups that are
out there demonizing their fellow
citizens demanding that they be censored
and then insisting that they should not
have to respond to public inquiries or
journalist inquiries about their work
these are behaviors that I think there
that we sometimes talk about how much of
the censorship is coming from the
culture is kind of wokism and cultural
wokism which is something that we're all
very familiar with and how much of it is
inorganic how much of it is coming from
government agencies how much of it is
being driven by the White House and you
know it's always like
you can never find the like there's no
real clear line because the people in
those agencies are True Believers and
and but it's but it's actually quite
pathological in the sense that they
don't want to go on your podcast they
don't want to they don't want to have to
justify their views they don't want to
have to debate publicly and they make up
a reason and the reason they make up is
that they don't want to platform evil
people like you and me
but I think we actually all know that
part of the perhaps the the real reason
might be that they don't actually feel
comfortable doing it because they
themselves don't really even understand
what they're doing they're in the grip
of an ideology that they assume to be
correct and everybody around them is
Nigeria but they haven't actually gone
and looked at the data they haven't
actually gone and interviewed the
researchers that are claiming to have
these increases of hate speech they're
not asking whether the statistics are
any good or how the data got collected
they're not doing any of that and so you
know for me I think that's the really
toxic thing that we need to blow apart
and blow it apart both in sort of
moralizing in favor of Free Speech but
also you have to just go to each
particular thing and go this claim maybe
it's true maybe anti-Semitism is
increasing and we just haven't seen the
right evidence for it but the evidence
has not been established and it needs to
be a terrible for anybody can make the
claim
that's fair but I would say there's a
part of me that despairs even adhering
that the answer is uh you know let's
look at the data because I've just been
through
uh hell over abuses of
the so-called data right as Norman
Fenton reveals the you know some of the
many tricks
um and so anyway I guess my point is to
the extent that this is apparently an
issue with
um political momentum behind it
one can expect the data not to be the
data right and it would be lovely if we
all just as we ought to all agree
that speech rights are Paramount and
that it is in all of our interests that
we'd be able to discuss the issues of
the day openly in order to figure out
what we believe should take place it is
also in our interest that we not pollute
the mechanisms of science so that we can
study questions like what is happening
with hate in general what is happening
with anti-Semitism and unfortunately we
live in an era where everything that can
be weaponized has been weaponized you
know so again this is like another
version of the Renee diresta point right
you find yourself uh suddenly aware
because of your political trajectory
or no your career trajectory of the
political dimension of Renee deresta but
you know weeks before you were in a
discussion nominally on the same side
trying to make sense you know
effectively at some level the CIA seems
to have reached into your sense making
discussion all right so that's an
interesting fact I mean I mean it's
funny but of course she wouldn't do any
interviews with me after I discovered
everything and um yeah I mean I think on
the point about I mean I don't have much
to add I would just say you know in
terms of the data I mean that's exactly
what I'm saying I don't think the data
speaks for itself but the data plus a
couple like honestly some smart guys
talking on a podcast and getting some
extra super power statistical help if I
need to I surround myself with people
that my wife is a statistician and
Norman Fenton and you know I don't know
if Alex guten talk now works here with
us
um you know and and the Norman Fenn
thing I think is special in part because
he was able to explain you know this to
somebody like me and so you kind of go
that's the right but that's but I think
the point is that the sensors are not
participating in that kind of discourse
they're actually
in fact there's yes
yeah but in other words the problem is
not that we have such a hard time
getting to the truth of it
um I do think part of the problem is the
scientism and the idea the the naive
idea that Sam Harris puts out there that
the data speaks themselves of course
speak for themselves of course they did
it don't speak for themselves we have to
interrogate the data you have to look at
how we're analyzing it
but really it's more like
I do think we're going to come to a
closer view on nuclear power the more
time we talk um I don't have total faith
in it I don't think we need to be
completely aligned but the fact that we
can have a conversation like this and be
able to do this in a free Society that's
really what matters and that's what's
being undermined and the tragedy is just
being undermined by people that claim so
much to care about that like Barack
Obama just kind of put it out there you
know I mean it's disappointing for me as
a Barack Obama voter to see Barack Obama
mindlessly repeat that anti-Semitism is
increasing without having just been like
for a moment and I don't think it's a
past part of the possible kind of going
you know I'm going to actually go the
White House asks me I'm not saying this
would happen but I'm just saying I
speculate the White House asked me to
retweet this I'm actually going to take
a minute and see if I really think
that's true I might even call because
I'm Barack Obama I can actually call any
expert in the world at any time of day
and ask them about their research and if
I call them because he's a smart guy
it's not dummy Obama certainly could
have called somebody and been like are
you accounting for maybe people
reporting this issue more rather than
actually experiencing it more
yes um which actually uh so two
important points one I want to come back
to
the issue you point to about the
possibility that they haven't controlled
for a change in level of reporting
is exactly analogous to an issue that I
think you missed when you said look
there's no evidence that terrorism is on
the rise
terrorism is absolutely on the rise
you know why
because they've redefined it yes
exactly they've redefined it so that a
person saying the evidence suggests that
uh Ivermectin is effective against covet
never mind whether you believe that but
a person saying I have looked at the
evidence and it suggests that Ivermectin
is effective against covid that person
is now according to the Department of
Homeland Security engaged in terrorism
that's where they've set the bar
that's an amazing fact but it's true you
can check it right Mal information
is defined as terrorism according to
their own taxonomy and the evidence does
suggest
we can debate how effective it is but
the evidence does suggest that
Ivermectin is effective against covid
um and so a person saying that by their
definition qualifies so anyway my point
would be you can either monkey with the
Baseline and create an artificial Trend
or you can monkey with the definitions
and create a trend out of a flat line
but we have to be aware of all of these
things because at some level I think the
punch line of this podcast is that the
story of Michael schellenberger is one
of trying to make sense in a Hall of
Mirrors and you're doing well I mean
you're finding a lot of the stuff but
God damn if it ain't a hollow mirrors I
mean you're looking it's everywhere
right the the how yeah it's crazy
um so okay can you take us back to the
story of the FBI whistleblowers what
happened to them well okay there's a so
there's a normal process that they all
followed which is that they first blow
the whistle within your own organization
but then Congress has specifically
passed laws that say that whistleblowers
can then go to Congress that's a
wonderful aspect of a democracy and
that's what they did and they went to uh
members of the house and they shared
their testimony and then they were all
basically punished I mean there was
retribution against them one guy they
relocated him in retaliation
um he got to the he moved he sold his
house moved the entire family across the
country
the first day they got there
uh they suspended him
without pay
um you know this kind of stuff you know
um you know and these are actually when
you actually when you interview them you
always said with whistleblowers because
whistleblowers are complic can be
complicated people but but with these
guys it was like you started
interviewing them and you'd be like and
you kind of go oh they're like Boy
Scouts they're like these are these are
the good these are the ones that don't
want to bend the rules these are the
ones that are that are actually have
memorized parts of the Constitution
these are people that um and you might
disagree with it and there's a debate
around you know interpretations of the
Constitution or whatever but these are
people that take this constitution at
its word
and they believe that they are loyal to
the Constitution above the FBI
um another word for people like that
might be Patriots
um
I mean it's just I I found myself
um these are very conservative people
I'm you know I'm sure again we disagree
on Plenty of things but I found myself
being quite impressed with the one I
interviewed three of them
um and my colleagues interviewed others
and uh they did it for the right reasons
and there's no evidence and no one's
really even charged that they did it for
the wrong reasons they they members of
Congress tried to smear them you know a
very typical thing it's always
um somehow you're connected to Trump you
know somebody that gave some money to
Trump you know contributed to one of the
non-profits and one of them has had that
kind of thing you know yes they're
conservatives you know I think they're
probably all Republicans so I didn't ask
how they voted
um but these are kind of who they appear
to be these are guys who are raised in
the blowing the whistle for an abuse of
power by by FBI
that um and that's been a problem really
since 9 11 you know and so the FBI
really hasn't been cleaned up it got
turned but they I think the basic
picture and I agree with it is that it
went from being a law enforcement
organization responding to evidence of
crime
to an intelligence gathering
organization and so you just the Classic
reason why we don't surveil all
Americans all the time it's not because
we don't think we would find a lot of
crime
you know it's a very important point you
know like you could spy on everybody and
you would find a lot more crime but
actually we don't do it that way for a
variety of reasons but it's in the
Constitution that we're not going to do
Mass surveillance because we believe in
innocent until proven guilty and the
onus is on the state to prove that
you're guilty and that usually means
that somebody some evidence has to come
to light that you're violating the law
we're not just going to start spying on
all of our fellow Americans particularly
because we don't like their politics
so that's you know this agency is out of
control the director you know agreed to
show a document alleging a criminal
bribery conspiracy involving Biden as
vice president they finally let the
members of Congress see the document
yesterday but they wouldn't give them
the document so now they're going to
file contempt of congress charges
against the director of the FBI so we
have agencies even if you're a Democrat
and you just think all Republicans are
evil ask yourself do you want an FBI
that half the country doesn't trust
that's exactly what percentage it is
it's 50 50. and if you think about it
for more than two seconds you'll know
that you want law enforcement
organizations that are broadly trusted
by Society otherwise you can't enforce
laws this is what happens is that Things
Fall Apart and societies stop being able
to enforce the laws and protect its
citizens when they become politicized
and directed at particular groups
so again you know I mean I I can't
disagree with anything you're saying but
I feel like you're underselling it
right
the fact is
you have to have intelligence agencies
if you're going to have intelligence
agencies at all and I believe we
probably need something
they have to be completely indifferent
to the politics of the people they are
investigating the rules have to be clear
here are the things you're allowed to do
and here are the things that you're not
allowed to do those rules have to be
spelled out in a way that we all
understand where those borders are and
then the intelligence agency
has to investigate violations completely
without any uh respect for one political
ideology or another it doesn't matter
that we are talking about a Democratic
president how could that possibly be
less relevant to the question of whether
or not Joe Biden committed a crime
against the United States
right influence peddling so
look you know you mentioned Hume this is
a rawlsian veil of ignorance question
yes right
patriotism is the recognition that you
want these things to be politically
indifferent you want them to do the jobs
that they have with complete
indifference to the politics of the
people that they are investigating
because I mean there are good reasons
like simple patriotism and decency but
even if you're looking for a selfish
reason you don't want these things
politicized because they will eventually
be used against you right that's the
simple way anybody can get it if you
allow this thing to become a tool of
politics it will be pointed at you
sooner or later so we can't afford it we
should all agree on the depoliticization
of these entities because it is a
requirement of the Republic to which we
belong
and
I don't know I
you also mention you know
Democrats who think all Republicans are
evil right my feeling is those people
are not doing right by their fellow
citizens
right I know a tremendous number of very
decent Republicans right there's no way
that I've found the 100 decent
Republicans and the rest of them are
evil the fact is there are lots of
people in the Republican Party who have
a point now I have no patience for that
party no patience no more patience for
it than I have for the Democratic party
I'm done with both of them but the
people in those parties are fellow
Americans right we are effectively on a
ship together we have aligned interests
almost completely until we get to the
point where we disagree or the
relatively small things
and we've got to stop looking at each
other this way I mean and in fact I
think what I'm trying to say to you
Michael is that The View
of the other side as unrestandably wrong
right just so far beyond the pale is
Downstream of weaponized mechanisms to
shape the narrative so that the people
on the other side of the political aisle
become monstrous to us and it is Our
obligation once you discover how uh how
deeply weaponized these things have
become it is Our obligation to throw out
the evidence that they've supplied us
because it's not in fact evidence
and you know I would even go so far I
was in that session yesterday with you
and and Bobby Kennedy and and Tulsi
gabbard and and Elon and uh David sacks
Robert Kennedy was saying
as is his way was simply reporting his
natural position on any issue about
which he was asked he was refreshingly
uh refusing to hedge on anything and
simply saying what he believes and
letting the cards fall while they may
and
the audience
responded very well indifferent to their
own political divisions with the man he
may be nominally on the blue team and
they may be nominally on the red team
but they were able to hear him because
he was speaking to basic principles that
are mostly Beyond politics and in some
sense
those things resonate with the majority
of Americans because they're common
sense
right and we have been denied the
ability to gather around common sense
together with people with whom we might
have some political divisions for so
long that we have forgotten that they
are indeed humans and that they are
indeed fellow citizens and that we do
indeed have a great deal of shared
interest
and shared history
so anyway that's got to come to an end
and I think the resonance that that
Bobby Kennedy is finding is is uh a
clear indication of what the hidden
tribes report found in what would that
be 2018
you know about the hidden yeah yeah
um
so anyway uh again I'm I'm fascinated by
seeing your trajectory through this
space and and uh where you're where
you're Landing thank you
I have to unfortunately I'm gonna have
to wrap up because I got to go back to
the story we're doing for tomorrow but
um just uh to mention you know we are
now public
sub stack that's the name of the
publication it's Leighton Woodhouse and
a bunch of other folks in us and people
can find us there and on Twitter and um
if you're in London on June 22nd we'd
love to see you
at Central Hall Westminster around 7 pm
cool
um do you have a few more minutes I
really have to I was I told them I would
be meeting with them at this point so
I'm going to have to jump if that's if
you're gonna have to go okay well we'll
have to save uh yeah it's been too long
save it for another time all right
Michael schellenberger it's been a real
pleasure and uh I'm looking forward to
uh a meeting down the road where we'll
have uh even more new and fascinating
stuff to discuss this sounds great
brother appreciate you
all right well
[Music]